what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel um today
i want to talk about a realization i
have
so
recently
i had a friend
that told me she could no longer be my
friend after like
20 plus years of friendship because of
this red pill stuff
and to me right i i don't really care
what people's opinions are i'll be
friends with anyone like if you're nice
to me and you're kind to me
and you believe some wild stuff to me
like i don't i don't care you do you i
might not follow you on instagram but
i don't care but this
this made me think like what information
tends to make people upset
and what i've realized is the
information that is closer to the truth
that is what upsets people like if there
is some truth of what i'm saying you
might disagree you might not think it's
100 true but if they're if there's a
glimmer of truth in what i say
that's when they get mad that's when
they explode because you don't explode
over something that's false
like
some i'm gonna i'm gonna give you an
example it's gonna be a little funny but
but in all seriousness i remember i had
a girl in middle school tell me that i
had a flat butt
and i was just like
i know i got the cake i know i got the
cake so
so i didn't i didn't care
and i was like oh whatever and that's
the thing like
when someone says something that you
know isn't true people don't care but
when you say something that has a hint
of truth in it
that's when people care so
that's just my observation about society
so
let me know if you guys agree with me i
could be wrong but let me know in the
comments i will talk to you guys later